os colegas se referiram de forma muito
apropriada acerca da paz e da saúde
sobre a paz
a gente se refere à pensão sendo que o
que mais se desenvolve que mais cresce
no mundo é o conflito do que na mesma
proporção não cresce é a nossa
capacidade humana de tratar de forma
adequada os conflitos
quando se fala em saúde saúde se fala e
se pensa e se percebe como uma condição
de qualidade de vida para se ter
qualidade de vida portanto se busca o
equilíbrio e o equilíbrio no sentido
holístico do termo um sistêmico uma
outra linguagem
a gente pensa e acredita que todo ponto
de vista é a vista de um ponto as coisas
talvez mais difíceis que nós temos pela
frente é desenvolver desenvolver a
capacidade de observar o que significa
observar observar sim juízo de valor
está incorporado nesse olhar é
extremamente difícil um ser humano se
desapegar da capacidade preconceituosa
de construir conceitos e verdades
absolutas dogmas é justamente sem
conhecer profundamente uma pessoa um
país um assunto uma um tema qualquer uma
das questões mais importantes que a
gente pergunta se refere basicamente de
que forma nós que somos governados pelo
nosso inconsciente de que forma nós por
meio da palavra ou da incapacidade da
escuta sensível
compassiva empática de que forma nós
somos produtores de violência por pelo
uso talvez inadequado das palavras
palavras fora de lugar a um deslocamento
de sentidos e significados e isso faz
com que haja a mágoa que haja a
discórdia que haja o conflito a
capacidade de observar deve ser seguida
ou poderia ser seguida pela nossa
capacidade de expressar sentimentos
talvez a nossa maior é o nosso maior
déficit seja no nosso vocabulário no que
se refere a responder uma simples
pergunta como é que você está se
sentindo talvez nós humanos tenhamos
nesse nessa pergunta uma grande dúvida
um grande abismo uma dificuldade de se
construir uma ponte uma fonte de luz
justamente nos faltam palavras para
responder essa pergunta se o corpo fala
e fala mesmo fala a vida como muito bem
foi comentado aqui é essa fala do corpo
é a expressão maior talvez dos nossos
sentimentos
além de observar aprender a observar sem
um juízo de valor sem o preconceito além
de aprendermos a educarmos os nossos
sentidos a partir da expressão dos
nossos sentimentos
talvez faça necessário que a gente
caminhe no sentido de perceber como
organizar e expressar quais as nossas
necessidades
se no item anterior expressar os
sentimentos e é uma expressão em relação
aquilo que nós observamos e nós
observamos aquilo que nós conseguimos
enxergar ou aquilo que a cultura que nós
estamos emergidas é faz com que a gente
veja somente aquilo que a gente acredite
justamente aquilo que a gente queira
confirmar as nossas crenças os nossos
valores
portanto nós somos seres animais
é da crença animais da demarcação do
território
demarcando território como uma forma de
poder e sempre que tem poder
a ausência de amor por último a gente
pensa na capacidade que precisamos
depois de observar mos depois de
desenvolver desenvolvermos a expressão
dos sentimentos em relação a essa
observação a organizarmos sistematizar
mas as nossas necessidades verbalizando
as para as pessoas com quem a gente
convive são as pessoas que mais a gente
produz conflitos são as pessoas que a
gente convive no dia a dia no trabalho
no estudo no nosso cotidiano e isso faz
com que a gente chega em uma última
questão que é a nossa capacidade de
desenvolver que todos nós temos
precisamos apenas a desenvolvê-la que é
estabelecer e direcionar as pessoas
certas
um pedido isso faz com que a gente possa
a fazer a gestão de um conflito a gestão
do conflito é administrar aquilo que é
verdadeiramente é fundamental qual seja
a a ideia de se buscar o caminho do
diálogo
se por um lado o conflito é o que mais
cresce no mundo o diálogo está cada vez
mais enfraquecendo a capacidade de
dialogar se quando se discute com alguém
vira e mexe todos nós de alguma forma
mais direta ou indireta
organizamos os argumentos para
contra-argumentar nós não escutamos
apenas ouvimos já dizia rubem alves que
nós precisamos neste país ampliar cursos
de escutar tória que curso de oratória
já estão muito bem ofertados por várias
organizações e as pessoas têm um mercado
bastante interessante
agora o que significa a gente
desenvolver a capacidade de escuta isso
eu considero particularmente a questão
mais difícil na vida porque é como se a
gente pudesse vestir o calçado
o colega que está do lado um calçado que
talvez não foi pensado não foi feito
para o formato do nosso pé para o
movimento do nosso andar para a partida
do nosso coração então a idéia de
aprender a escutar é vai além da
possibilidade fisiológica de saber ouvir
escutar talvez seja como alguém já falou
muito bem né e se colocar no lugar do
outro a pergunta é é possível sentir
menos a dor do outro
será que aquilo que o almodôvar já
colocou em um de seus filmes né
a capacidade da gente vestir a pele de
outra pessoa
será que isso é possível talvez sim
talvez não cada um vai ter que construir
a sua própria resposta porque respostas
prontas e racionalizados
o mundo está repleto o nosso maior
problema principalmente que vêm do
centro do coração das universidades do
chamado mundo ocidental
talvez seja essa força essa ditadura da
racionalização sentimentos não se sente
nas universidades se racionaliza se
estuda os sentimentos mas não se aprende
a sentir as nossas salas de aulas
deveriam ser laboratórios de sentimentos
e não-formal formalização e formulações
e teorias acerca de como enquadrar o
comportamento em uma das gavetas dos
conceitos que são de forma ortodoxa as
separam as pessoas e os pesquisadores e
e por decorrência os próprios alunos
isso é uma violência simbólica uma
violência bastante cíclica que de uma
forma ou outra a gente sem querer
querendo e sem querer reproduz a
reprodução da violência seja ela
simbólica ou física é algo que nos chama
bastante atenção então se a ideia se
almas uma certa concordância digamos
assim
e é o que mais cresce é o conflito e no
mesmo no mesmo grau e na mesma proporção
e na mesma radicalidade é não não não se
ampliam as ações no sentido de se
ampliar a forma de fazer o tratamento
adequado desse conflito
nós percebemos então que é necessário
que todas as iniciativas do campo da
cultura no campo da política que possa a
ser voltada aquilo que mais nos
interessa que é reaprender a capacidade
humana de enxergar a humanidade no outro
essa esse movimento de alteridade faz
com que a gente recebe fique a vida de
um sentido aquilo que não existe sentido
que é a vida a vida têm sentidos que as
pessoas constrói ao longo de suas vidas
ao contrário disso é aquela pessoa que
tenta de alguma forma ou outra impor o
seu sentido como sendo o sentido
verdadeiro para as demais pessoas nas
mediações de conflitos é comum a gente
observar que o ódio se transforma em
amor e o amor se transforma em ódio e
sim as pessoas têm oportunidade de ter
um terceiro alguém de fora do conflito
que as faça perceber que a sua cura está
dentro dela própria
assim como foi falado anteriormente se
referindo à moderna psicoterapia ou a
própria medicina os pacientes saem de
casa acreditando acreditando que o
médico ou que o terapeuta o psicanalista
o psicólogo a psicóloga e irá pôr a luta
transfere transfere terceiriza assim
como as pessoas principalmente no nosso
brasil mais de 200 milhões de habitantes
nós temos 100 milhões de ações judiciais
as pessoas transferem para o superego da
sociedade o poder judiciário para o juiz
a capacidade de decidir os conflitos que
elas próprias criaram então nós estamos
mergulho
dados numa verdadeira fragilidade humana
no nosso país e isso é preciso reverter
é preciso que as pessoas acreditem em si
próprias
não sei se isso é suficiente mas seria
um ponto emergencial a emergência de
acreditar em si própria e pra buscar
esse empoderamento as pessoas
precisariam enxergar nas outras pessoas
aquilo que elas pensam que só acontece
com elas
então quando se senta num círculo um
círculo da paz um círculo de justiça
restaurativa em um círculo de mediação
tão antigo e tribo tribal assim como o
xamanismo que atualizando essa linguagem
essa contribuição humana o milenar
taoísmo se encontra com a física
quântica principalmente nesse momento em
que a gente observa que a energia a
energia que circula no círculo de
tratamento do conflito é uma energia que
tende a fazer com que as pessoas
enxerguem a responsabilidade que têm e
tiveram na construção daquele problema
que cada um acredita que seja o
responsável o outro se utiliza se
utilizando de uma forma religiosa hã hã
segundo a qual a culpa a culpa ea
vergonha já estragaram as vidas de
muitas pessoas muitas pessoas muitas
pessoas mesmo e para além do tempo e do
espaço e para além do certo e do errado
existe um lugar que eu gostaria de me
encontrar com vocês muito obrigado